[Musique]
2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
drogue put violence put non ce n'est pas
le dernier morceau de caris c'est le
quotidien pour des milliards de français
mais derrière cette façade sympathique
de [ __ ] et de violence se cache une
réalité bien plus dramatique nous avons
suivi durant plusieurs jours le
quotidien de l'unité d'intervention
secrète spécialisé dans les crimes
commis par des extraterrestres à cette
unité est plus communément appelée
huisclos ce culte mais comment parodie
le film on va appeler ça les men in
black nous suivons les agents fps qui
doit aujourd'hui intervenir sur un crime
[Musique]
nous passerons
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le suspect est maîtrisé les agents
procèdent maintenant à l'interpellation
tu fais quoi là
tu vas en contrebas des crocs là tu me
racontes pas des crocs
obama visiblement
l'habitude à force
maintenant que le souhaitait le cas loin
les deux agents vont procéder à une
série de tests classiques mais
infaillible afin de vérifier et
contrôler l'état physique de l'individu
très bien madame je vous demander de
souffler dans le ballon
oui mais voilà tu as tu balances et est
infaillible qui marche presque toujours
rapides souvent qu'à l'accoutumée
au bout de quelques minutes les
résultats tombent bon eh bien tu as tu
du ballon et négatifs c'est un joli
petit chien parfaitement réglementaire
quatre petites pattes aux deux pays de
caux bien rebondi donc non tout va bien
c'était donc une fausse alerte l'homme
ont pas traîner comme ça le soit un
chacun voit midi à quatorze heures en ce
moment reprenez votre souffle sur la
waho qu'est ce que c'est que ce soit
lors pour en sort on a quoi qu'est ce
que c'est ça qu'est ce que c'est que la
caisse que c'est quoi c'est une
disquette d'informations digitales une
possession hautement illégal de
catégorie 3 le suspect peut prétendre à
une peine allant jusqu'à trois jours de
prison avec sursis et une amende de 43
euros
nous allons utiliser le mdc donc c'est
un appareil qui permet d'effacer la
mémoire et de révéler le visage des
extraterrestres savez madame du coup je
vais vous demander de regarder paris s'y
prête c'est merci
bon [ __ ] ex terrestre
un extraterrestre un visiteur venu d'une
lointaine galaxie
l'identité est temps confirmé l'équipe
maintenant ramener la créature au
commissariat un tu veux raconter des
craques là tu me raconter des craques
alors ça suffit pas parce que je suis
pas née du dernier ouvrage allez allez
c'est bon on y va je remarque dans le
panier à free allez
mais ça de prime abord est assez du du
mdx et du matériel digital informatique
j'ai un cousin que je soupçonne être mon
frère du fait d'une étrange récemment ce
qui pourra peut-être nous aider il
travaille au laboratoire analyse ah
ouais
[Musique]
celui-ci le laboratoire d'analysé hawaï
oui j'ai bien reçu de matériel digital
informatique peinture jeux pourris mes
couilles etc je commence à analyser les
résultats restent insupportables ouais
bon ok aujourd'hui on va parler de men
in black aujourd'hui quand un nouveau
film men in black sort tout le monde
fait
[Musique]
à la fin des années 90 men in black
c'était un phénomène pour rappel on y
retrouve les aventures de gie qui se
retrouvent embauché dans une
organisation gouvernementale secrète
ayant pour charge de surveiller les
extraterrestres présents sur terre et
désolé si ça vous choque mais ça veut
dire que les men in black c'est
l'équivalent galactique du lieutenant
dupont qui emmerdent mamadou cette fois
par jour pour avoir ses papiers
d'identité le film était porté par tommy
lee jones est évidemment will smith
révélée par la série le prince de bel
air et d'autres blockbusters comme bad
boys ou independence day évidemment
comme toute licence qui marche le film a
dû écarter les jambes pour se laisser
traire par des commerciaux avides de
pognon on a eu droit notamment un dessin
animé reprenant les personnages de will
smith tommy lee jones et dominique
strauss kahn dont le seul truc que les
gens se souviennent aujourd'hui c'est le
générique
et ben non c'est pas vrai moi je m'en
souviens c'était trop calqué jean
pustules je t'écoute raconte de
l'histoire
et bien sûr nous on est là pour parler
de jeux vidéo si je pourrais être exact
alors la plupart sont des tps avec
autant d'intérêt qu'ont livrée à
quelques fps et des jeux de plateforme
sur gameboy assez médiocre et
aujourd'hui on va surtout parler du tout
premiers men in black the game sorti en
97 sur playstation
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le sel [ __ ] le moment agréable dans
cette émission commence le jeu en jouant
will smith comme dans le film qui est
appelé en renfort pour un cambriolage
les développeurs du jeu ayant autant
d'imagination qu'un enfant dans le coma
le jeu est donc qu'elle de resident evil
je vais donc forcément faire beaucoup de
comparaisons avec sept autres jeux
sortis en 96 soit eux d'en avants men in
black donc en arrivant dans l'appart
vous affrontez un premier ennemi et là
attention on va parler notre client la
prétendue ouverture facile des briques
de lait je suis d'accord c'est un vrai
problème mais on va plutôt parler de
maniabilité c'est toujours dur de faire
comprendre les problèmes de maniabilité
sans vous la mettre dans les mains je
parle de la manette mais la maniabilité
est scandaleuse à votre personnage se
dirige comme un [ __ ] de bateaux week
si difficile de jouer
combien a coûté ce 46 euros et 60
centimes et au delà des déplacements
c'est surtout les combats qui pose
problème pour vous donner une idée dans
resident evil lorsque vous vouliez tirez
vous deviez appuyé sur r1 en faisant
cela à votre personnage se fige lève son
arme et ensuite tout se faisait avec le
bouton d'action si vous étiez anjou vous
diriez et si vous étiez en mode normal
le bouton d'action servait à tout le
reste ramasser les objets ouvrir les
portes cuir un kebab et c'est normal in
black le bouton pour lever son arme
n'est pas la gâchette mais le bouton
rond alors oui c'est stupide mais bon
après tout il ya bien des gens qui
croient au réchauffement climatique
bref une fois que vous êtes en mode
combat si vous avez une arme à la main
votre personnage se mélangent ou et vous
tirez avec les touches de direction
qu'est donc on est bien parti ni vos
compétences sont nés quelque part entre
la maternelle et cp bref retour au
niveau 1 donc après avoir chaussé des
trois types vous devrez donc désamorcer
une bombe
au
[Musique]
québec c'est pas bon câble et je reviens
à l'écran titre sulky veut dire que je
vais recommencer depuis le début à
chaque fois que je meurs alors on peut
faire ça ou alors je peux prendre ce jeu
et me le mettre bien profondément le
fret qu'est ce que tu fais c'est
totalement interdit bref après trois
autres game over parce que la solution
n'était pas de cliquer sur un de ces
énormes câble de couleurs super bien mis
en évidence mais de regarder ce petit
machin au centre comme dans le film une
course poursuite un temps s'engage dans
les rues de new york
pardon essai de course poursuite fait
place ensuite comme dans le film à
l'affrontement avec la lienne
déjà commençons par le point positif le
jeu est traduit en français possède
également les vraies voix françaises de
will smith et tommy lee jones mais buket
vous en faites un ami le point négatif
en revanche c'est que comme le jeu a été
programmé par des poules deux fois sur
trois les personnages balancent leurs
répliques complètement au hasard
messieurs
petits cochons petits cochons pour moi
est les messieurs c'est l'heure de
mourir maintenant m mais bon ça à la
limite on s'en fout et vrai problème
c'est que le jeu ne possède quasi aucune
musique juste des ambiances sonores
et ont 120
à écouter ça
et c'est censé être la viande de
vaisseau alien alors pourquoi j'ai
l'impression d'être un hôpital à côté du
grand père en fait trôner est d'ailleurs
en parlant des aliens c'est pareil pour
l'heure bruitages vous appelez ça ok
alors là tu es un extra terrestre était
en train de mourir
écoute jean michel bref à la fin du
niveau 1 comme dans le film après avoir
arrêté la lienne votre personnage
encontre qu'à et s'ensuit une petite
scène cinématique qui explique votre
recrutement et à partir de ce moment là
vous aurez donc accès à la fameuse base
des men in black l'épicentre de toute la
vie extraterrestre présentes sur terre
peut-être que c'est férié aujourd'hui au
nom regarder attendait ya un
extraterrestre gardien
mais voilà je vous avais dit que c'était
pas de la merde c'est juste eu une
énorme fenêtre de pis c'est aussi à
partir de ce moment là vous aurez accès
à tout l'arsenal finis les vieux flemme
tous pourris du diois place aux flingues
en métal chromé de technologie
extraterrestre
nique
ta mère
[Musique]
et
[ __ ] dans le film et détruit des
bagnoles plus vite le twitter des tricks
cerveau des gens et la jouer des coudes
babouche qui font le plus mal que mes à
remanier d'ultra secrètes ou alors t'es
balles font les bons dégâts et c'est ton
coup de pied qui fait super mal quoi
justement j'étais en train de vous
parler des combats au corps à corps
parce que c'est là le vrai fun commence
et par fun je veux évidemment dire que
ça pue la merde en mode combat au corps
à corps de la même façon que pour le
flingue lorsque vous appuyez sur rond
votre personnage se bloque au sol pour
mettre des coups et le souci est le même
que pour les flingues l'angle toléré par
le jeu est beaucoup trop faible du coup
la moindre basson ressemble à un combat
entre deux aveugles le bourret et
pourquoi je ne touche pas là pourquoi je
touche pas au pied posé sur sa tête j'ai
la chaussure à prendre sur son crâne
[ __ ] et en plus comme ce jeu de ces
morts ils te file des balles en mousse
au bout de deux epita plus de munitions
et du coup y combat sur dix de fond au
corps à corps
ok ok
tout va bien
guerre du calme
je pense à quelque chose c'est quelque
chose qu'il était
vim
c'est mieux
j'ai pas dit mais depuis tout à l'heure
on voit des images du niveau 2 parce
qu'elle évidemment tout le monde se
souvient de ce passage dans le film qui
se passe dans une base en antarctique et
je pourrai pas sortir malheureusement
mon traditionnel mais je n'ai pas vu le
film ou quoi parce que là pour le coup
la réponse est non effectivement vu le
timing men in black a forcément été
développé en parallèle du film et il est
clair quand on voit le résultat que les
devs n'avait aucune idée de ce à quoi
pouvait ressembler le film est la preuve
il suffit de regarder le design des
aliens dans le jeu julie roy
on dirait des résultats quand tu tapes
costumes extraterrestre pas cher sur
google c'est nos costumes et on le voit
aussi sur l'histoire du jeu qui du coup
n'a aucune cohérence par exemple dans le
niveau 1 tout le truc du niveau c'est
que à la fin vous trouvez une espèce de
statut olmèques je veux dire quand tout
le niveau consiste à trouver un objet en
général tu te dis que c'est important
mais pourtant à la cinématique suivante
la statuette que vous avez découverte
serait d'origine olmèques d'après nos
experts j'ai pensé que ça vous
intéresserait alors qui va partir sur la
banquise ouais je crois que c'est
d'origine le mec mais regardons plutôt
cette mission en antarctique et qui n'a
aucun rapport avec ce que vous venez de
vivre et c'est ça à chaque niveau
mission de en antarctique donc battu
récupère une protéine ultra secrète nous
avons analysé le composent et que vous
avez ramené c'est une protéine
extrêmement rare mais nous avons
d'autres problèmes
dire
et on arrive donc au niveau 3 et c'est
là que le jeu devient vraiment la foire
à la saucisse alors je vais encore
parler de resident evil parce que men in
black a aussi choisi un système de
caméras fixes mais dans resident evil
les caméras étaient en général assez
proche du personnage ne serait ce que
pour maintenir le sentiment d'angoissé
et qu'une salle était grande et bien la
caméra change et dax plusieurs fois dans
la même salle et ça c'est bien par
contre mettre une caméra un 10 km 2
adepoju avec louer vos [ __ ] de
personnages sur l'écran et mettre tous
les niveaux de nuit il sort dix voix
encore plus que dalle ça c'est de la
merde ce niveau il est fou c'est le
genre de niveau tu envoies un tous les
milieux tous les tableaux ils ont l'air
d'être filmée depuis un hélicoptère et
le revend jusque dans les tripes que les
développeurs il en avait plus rien à
branler à ce moment là regardez la
sortie de l'écran de ce personnage ma
planète a besoin de moi
poitiers meurt en regagnant la planète
c'est aussi le moment où ils se sont dit
attends c'est la nuit on voit rien mais
dans une phase de plateforme
ce passage c'est littéralement un festin
c'est comme si une infirmière venait de
pisser dessus sur ton les morts la
caméra est tellement loin et c'est
tellement sombre je suis même pas alors
quel sens je suis tourné et en plus
regardées c'est même pas des plats sont
purement horizontale pour simplifier y
en a même qui montent et qui descendent
et apprécié à faire et quelle bande
d'abrutis totalement fini à la pisse a
dû bosser sur ce jeu pour arriver en
résulte ainsi la menthe ok c'est bon
j'ai compris ce passage c'est une orgie
de chiasse ans prêts étalés sur les murs
dans une nuit noire c'est la mort de la
logique de la physique de tous les trucs
en x etc ont gêné oui oui oui oui c'est
du lourd oui mais bien même le jeu il le
dit et il dit de trucs aussi mais les
répliques et scoop avant la fin
j'ai vraiment aux horreurs de ce jeu
s'ils touchent que je mets tout ce que
je mérite je devrais me trouvez un autre
jeu nous regretterons l'agent j
souvenons nous de ces dernières paroles
ou alors après je pense que c'était un
problème d'émulation parce que soyons
honnêtes ce passage est impossible à
passer sans émulateurs bref on a eu le
meilleur résumé j'annule la plateforme
est inadmissible les phases d'action
sont injouables même les puzzles et les
énigmes sont fois réjean plus loin vous
arrivez dans une grosse pièce ronde ya
aucune autre issue aucun objet avec
lequel interagir vous êtes en bas des
escaliers la caméra est centrée sur un
gros cercle et si tu marches dessus
j'annule tumeur parce qu'en fait la
solution c'était pas de marcher dessus
enfin c'était de taper les
extraterrestres invisible sur les
clairanencs beau ouvrir une porte ah
ouais bien sûr mais c'est quoi ce truc
là c'est le font entendre de croo quick
le machin il a même plus de texture
voulait bien peut pas faire semblant de
bosser au moins ça va vous avez déjà vu
un extraterrestre pour me dire à quoi ça
sert
écoutez vous savez quoi merci on a tous
vu les résultats de mon analyse
est bonne journée après avoir été
interpellé l'individu est ramené au
poste des men in black section ille et
vilaine pour y être interrogé sur
quand je te pose une question tu me
réponds à moi je te pose une question
surtout ne coupe pas la parole déjà là
bas il ya la barrière du respect la
voilà donc on a un individu visiblement
de type extra terrestre en provenance de
la planète anubis rapport avec le dieu
égyptien
non non c'est parce que ils ont deux
anus en fait
j 3
[Musique]
le suspect c'est ce qu'ils encourent il
décide par les seuls à seuls quelques
minutes avec son avocat pour établir une
ligne de défendre elle a le droit le
droit donc là on peut qu'attendre donc
on espère après que la conversation avec
son avocat que que le suspect fera table
après quelques minutes finalement le
suspect décide de passer aux aveux
problème notre seigneur suprême arrivera
bientôt le voyageur cosmique plus
riviera maya mexique et lavera de ses
péchés en réduisant votre manette
l'individu au juste nommé
seigneur suprême
soit
s'accaparer
s'accaparer ça prend un cas ou deux
j'ai reçu les résultats du laboratoire
analyse il apparaît que nous ne sommes
pas cousin c'est juste un problème de
mangaka
par contre sur le concernant le test du
jeu et les résultats indiquent une forte
concentration en énergie jaune
[Musique]
là je dois dire que je suis largué il
faut dire qu'en général dans les jdg je
passe les mises en scène parce que moi
y'a que les tests qui m'intéresse en
tout cas personne ne s'attendait à cette
rencontre du troisième type
oh [ __ ] rollier un truc cap était là
haut la marche lancez-vous
deux mois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
seigneur suprême
nous avons là j'aime l'énergie jaune est
à nous quand vient le temps de mettre
notre point
[Musique]
passez-moi le président sud
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allô allô rapid eye l'a pas aimé la
chanson allez on reprend les autres
lalala
[Musique]
oh
la valla
alors
là
aulas
oh
[Musique]